[Music]
20:17 was the year that we also lost
some true comedy legends
to look at the world through a child's
eyes is the biggest key to everything
that I have ever done
Jerry Lewis is acting in comedy career
spanned eight decades but too many he
will be most remembered for his annual
Labor Day telethon for the Muscular
Dystrophy Association he was so adorable
I am always thankful for the very same
thing and that was that I got up this
morning and I'm thankful to God that
there is the possibility that I'll be up
tomorrow morning this year also marked
the passing of Dick Gregory not only was
he a stand-up comedian
but he was also known as a
groundbreaking civil rights activists
she had hidden a white folk talking cold
the average typical American family is
two and a half children per family and I
thought y'all really had half ones we
also lost comedian Don Rickles he was
known as the king of insults you say
hello and they show two seconds yes two
seconds of nothing what we loved him
because he also poked fun at himself
like when he won an Emmy in 2008 for a
comedy special in 55 years this is one
of my great treats in life and blue
cross is waiting in the truck to take me
away and we said goodbye to comedian
Charlie Murphy charlie was best known
for his work on the sketch comedy hit
Chappelle's Show and says his humor was
created by growing up with his brother
Eddie Murphy
Eddie was eight years old he was already
telling world-class jokes about me
[Music]